the eye-watering spike in the cost of
gas is painful for consumers and
businesses this is the price of
wholesale gas and it's up more than 500
percent since the start of the year all
countries are facing the same
stratospheric surge in prices but when
it comes to generating electricity some
are better insulated against the impact
let's look at the uk's energy mix at
midday on monday gas made up almost 50
percent renewables around a quarter
nuclear a little over 10
and there's a little bit there from coal
too
compare that to last october and you can
see renewables are roughly the same but
we're using a lot more gas now and
that's to make up for a sharp drop in
nuclear generation as half a dozen
reactors have been shut down for
maintenance
it's a very different situation in
france there almost 80 percent of
electricity is generated with nuclear
energy gas makes up less than 10
significantly less than the uk so the
direct impact on electricity consumers
is much lower
france also generates enough energy to
export to other countries
germany also has a very different energy
mix to the uk just 13 of its electricity
was generated with gas at midday
but look at coal it made up almost a
third but germany's heavy use of coal
comes with a climate cost the dirtiest
of all the fossil fuels produces the
equivalent of around 800 grams of carbon
dioxide per kilowatt of energy that's
twice as much as gas for comparison
offshore wind is just 10 grams per
kilowatt
coal just does not fit inside the carbon
budgets that we have and it doesn't fit
inside the international commitments
that we're signing up to
and on the economics point
it's cheaper than gas at the minute but
the lesson from the gas crisis should be
that fossil fuel prices are very fickle
very volatile
and coal could just as easily become
expensive another time so rather than
trying to
pick the least worst fossil fuel and
hoping it stays cheap
you should be trying to move away from
fossil fuels entirely back to
homegrown renewables
the energy crunch is worldwide india's
135 coal power stations which generate
70 percent of the country's electricity
have their own supply crisis more than
half have stocks to last just three days
with blackouts a growing reality as
economies are restarting after the
pandemic energy is in high demand